so the geniuses in the strategy division
over at the DNC assumed they could ride
the Russia hoax all the way to a midterm
win but poll suggests that might not be
working out so now they're going after
the administration's economic record
unemployment is pretty low the stock
market is pretty high so instead the
attack is on gas prices which are going
up and that is bad for the middle class
something to be worried about the
problem of course is the Democratic
Party has spent years vowing to increase
gas prices if elected in the name of
stopping global warming the 2016
platform literally demanded a higher tax
Mark Steyn is an author and columnist he
was alive in 2016 paying attention he
may remember that plank in the platform
what does he make of it now hey Mark
well hi hi Tucker yeah it's it's kind of
any port in a storm the Blue Wave has is
petering out as it comes towards shore
and you said the Russia hoax I mean you
got to think in the chancelleries of the
world right now
if if all the people who told us that
Trump had no chance to win in 2016 if
somehow the blue wave doesn't happen and
the Republicans win the midterms there's
a huge opportunity for a sinister
foreign power out there that they can
get the Democrats to blame them for
stealing the election so we can have a
slovenia investigation or a tajikistan
investigation or a solomon islands
investigation so if you're the solomon
islands ambassador now would be a really
good time to book a lunch with say mitch
mcconnell so it'll look suspicious on
the wednesday morning after in a
november and i don't want to give any
ideas to the DNC or the FBI but if the
FBI has any spare cambridge professors
lying around that it would like to you
know say two minor trump officials you
know maybe a staffer to mitch mcconnell
oh you know that slovenia has all those
DNC emails I mean you gotta figure this
is the time to be moving on to the next
plot now that Russia hasn't worked out
so you
laughing about this but the next
independent council or maybe four
independent councils from now will be
pulling this tape and using it at
evidence yeah yeah now you're trying no
that's right what did I know and when
did I do it I mean one of the thing I
mean just to be serious here for a
moment because I don't really take this
thing that seriously I think the
Democrats actually have a problem with a
lack of message and to profess now to be
concerned about gas prices after they've
derided the the Trump tax Carter's
crumbs and all the rest of it I mean I
think actually the solution is not to
play to replace the Russia investigation
with with gas prices the solution is to
figure out that Trump connected with
millions and millions of people who
switched on the TV and found neither the
Republican nor Democrat establishments
right in the least bit concerned about
them and that's the difference that's
yeah I mean the new middle-class life
expectancy as if yesterday is down for
the third year in a row why don't they
run on that but they don't care that's
not wrong no I mean I gotta ask you
about Harvey Weinstein so because I
can't control myself
obviously the ExxonMobil megiddo nor
Hillary Clinton super favor he sets a
term stuff in to authorities in New York
on sex crime charges right this stories
based so this is a Dana mom of the story
do you want to put a bow on it what
should we think of this well you're
right about the Hillary connection they
actually had lunch to discuss after her
defeat Harvey Weinstein making the
documentary about Hillary's defeat
that's how tied in they are I think this
is I think this is quite important
though because the me to movement you
know there's an element of moral panic
to it but there's no doubt about this
guy he's been credibly accused of rape
by actresses in the United States Canada
the United Kingdom France New Zealand
all over the planet and this tells us
something about the the way a wealthy
and powerful men use things like
confidentiality agreements
to silence people and get away with
their crimes for decades on end and
that's the lesson here don't live in
silence don't live in fear and frankly
things like confidentiality agreements I
think should have a far more
circumscribed place in American life I
mean there's also I agree with
everything you've said but there's also
a sub lesson here which is if you're
wondering what people are up to look at
the behavior that they denounce in
public it's probably the very same thing
I mean Harvey Weinstein was this great
champion of women as was Schneiderman
you know the one thing I'm not in favor
of is hurting women and of course they
were both doing that exactly that exact
thing I don't think it's an accident
no and I also think that's a liberal
thing by the way is you you care about
you profess to care about people in
general so you care about third-world
people in general or gays in general or
Muslims in general and you take that as
a license to trash and abuse people in
particular and that's what ties harvey
weinstein Schneiderman and a lot of
these mostly Democrat mostly liberal
figures to get together they said all
the right things in public and then
they've got the you know the the the the
door lock button under the desk in
private and they've and they've got the
the standard non-disclosure agreement
and stacked in triplicate inside the
desk it's being yeah and that's and
that's what they all have in common they
love humanity in general and abuse
humans in particular it's perfect if
reading and writing still exists once
this revolution is over I'll be really
excited to read the history of this
period you know that it stands back it
makes sense that it said I hope you
write it mark Stein thank you